let's get the Trump administration
perspective tonight on the latest polls
the Bolton book other topics Kellyanne
Conway is counselor to the president
Kellyanne thanks for being here
good evening Bret I want to start out
with this this book the administration
has been fighting to prevent it from
being released going to court over it
the John Bolton is now out doing
interviews he'll be as I mentioned on
special report next week he is saying
and it's in the book that the president
from what he saw in the room is unfit
for office what do you say to that well
a couple things when people do tell-all
books I'd prefer that they tell us all
what they accomplished in those
positions so I've known John for a long
time served alongside of him in the
White House for all 17 months he was
there and I much of his national
security accomplishments that happened
and there are many in the Donald Trump
presidency happened before he got there
or after he left the capture of al
Baghdadi soleimani sanctioning the ICC
getting the Afghan troop withdrawal down
to almost half and and with the target I
talked to our national security
administrator today or director today
Robert ambassador Robert O'Brien said
we'll probably get to zero by May of
2021 so many of these things have
happened since he's gone and I like when
people tell us all that they
accomplished I also would point out and
others have done this that ambassador
Bolton John Bolton had many nice things
to say about the president complimentary
but I think the one that's most
important to some of the allegations in
his book is what he said in the White
House briefing room he said quote since
2017 January 2017 President Trump has
been taking decisive action against
election meddling and interference in
his book he claims that the president is
asking President Xi to help him win
farmers in the Midwest this makes no
sense I personally have had private
meetings with John Bolton where we've
discussed Chinese fentanyl for example
since I run the drug crisis at the White
House and he never said to me gee Kelly
and we have a problem with getting the
Chinese pencil analogs scheduled as
president she has promised because after
all the president president Chavez asked
and helped in the election so some of
this smacks people's brand new
information and false as well I know
you're in
ruin him next week and I would just
remind you that and everybody who's
watching that Bolton decide these books
are never fact checked so you
interviewed James Comey in December of
2019 or 2018 and he lied to you he lied
to you and you called him on it and he
was it was revealed that he lied to you
he didn't know he said he doesn't know
that the Democrats funded the sales
hacia you said what do you mean you
don't know what he said I still don't
know it is the fact the Republicans did
you said no you correctly said no they
didn't and it turned out when we saw the
FISA warrants that an honor about
October 12 2016 he had been briefed
about that and then he included that
unverified dossier which is a French
word for a load of bunk sure I'm in the
briefing sure you're in presidential
you're saying that in this book there
are lies and that his perception is not
accurate here but yet lake says Bouldin
himself is a legendary note-taker who
keeps a detailed record of his life one
of his former staffers told me this is
Eli Lake that Bolton takes notes on what
he had for breakfast
also if Bolton's book is all lies why
would the White House try to block its
publication and claim he is revealing
classified information Bolton's account
of the trip I didn't say that
because it's devastating it's
devastating excuse me I'm sorry there's
a little delay Brett I didn't mean to
interrupt so no I didn't say it was all
lies what I said was it's important to
put it all in the perspective of the
tenure that he had there what has
happened since he left and the fact that
he didn't raise any of this in a
meaningful way while he was there and I
will tell you that those of us who do
work there are duty-bound we took a note
of the Constitution we work for the
country we are duty-bound to give advice
and try to brief the President and
breanne and work with other members of
the cabinet of the senior staff the
outside world Congress certainly on any
number of issues to try to improve this
country that's what we're trying to do
there so I know he's a note-taker I
wouldn't miss it firsthand and all I'm
saying is I think we need context here
that ambassador dabble and as somebody
who was crediting the president not just
for being decisive
around the globe on many different on
many different actions in fact he's on
tape saying that many times but the one
that really caught my eye today when I
went back through some of it was him in
the White House press briefing room
saying that for the entire presidency of
Donald Trump President Trump has taken
quote decisive action against election
meddling and interference and does
anybody believe that the president asked
President Xi to help him win the
election it's so ridiculous in fact
ambassador delight Heiser was asked it
with no warning yesterday by Senator
Menendez and hearing about other issues
and ambassador white Heiser was under
oath and immediately said immediately
spontaneous he said never happened I was
there and reported so ambassador white
Heiser is saying this is in the room
that where it didn't happen so I think
look these other a lot of books out
there that turn out to have tremendous
falsities I don't know why these books
aren't fact checked even names are wrong
dates are wrong sometimes quotes are
attributed to somebody positively and
somebody else said it they weren't even
there so I do I'm glad you'll have a
chance to interview him I think that's
important I think the departed justice
has made clear it's unusual to release a
book like this while people that you
work with are still doing their jobs and
while the president is still in office
that's the unusual part well other
people have done it we had former
secretary Bob gates who wrote a book
about the Obama administration while he
was still in office other people have
done it but you're right to be this
pointed in this direct there are a lot
of things that are getting picked yet
picked up I want to quickly I only have
a few seconds is this rally happening in
Tulsa 100 percent it's not going to be
moved outside it's it's definitely going
to happen the information I have from
the campaign is that it's happening and
I think people want to get out there and
express their beliefs peaceably you've
seen people do it through protests
through peaceful protests and otherwise
and you're seeing you're going to see
people whether it's in Tulsa or elsewise
Brett they want to participate in our
great democracy also I also would say
that Oklahoma I believe is in phase
three and so you can have gatherings of
a certain number in doors and I know
that people are adhering to the
protocols but we can't pick and choose
who can be where wearing a mask or not
based on our politics based on whether
some people think that folks are
irredeemable and deplorable they have
the same rights as anybody else to
peacefully assemble peaceably assemble
under our Constitution and I think it's
important that they do that also I know
you were talking a lot about the poll
since I'm was a pollster for many years
yeah respectfully we never did one
single national poll when I was campaign
manager of Trump ends 2016 why they're a
colossal waste of time and money
statewide polls are really the gold
standard David Plouffe another
successful campaign manager for
President Obama backed me up on that
yesterday and said these are like 50
different governor's races
state-by-state
let's look at those statewide polls and
I think the polls in the States right
now are about where I would expect them
to be depending on the poll with Trump
invited both under 50% and most of those
statewide polls and within a few points
of each other I saw that in 2016 the day
Donald Trump asked me to become the
campaign manager in August and we saw
they were both under 50 they were within
a couple points of each other and then
you go into the state-by-state we know
President Trump and vice president pence
are going to spend more time out in
those swing states then Joe Biden ever
Ken and they will be connecting directly
talking about the proxy port of the
Trump administration and laying out the
vision for the next four years well
that's definitely a national poll out
tonight but we do swing state polls and
battleground state polls as well
Kellyanne we appreciate your time thank
you Brad